all right hopefully you've had a weekend
to watch smell desolate so yeah let's
talk about some desolation of smaug
spoilers here and yeah that's an
official spoiler warning so if you get
the hobbit the desolation of smaug
spoiled for you because you stuck around
this video after that spoiler warning
that is officially on you my friend that
means I stick around if you want one of
the things I love about this movies it
shows how Bilbo is a burglar how good
hobbits are being stealthy little
burglars so spy like they could take out
the one in Stratego and not too far into
the movie Bilbo takes on some spiders
that was a really creepy scene I'm not
just saying that because I just don't
like spiders I'm saying that because it
was a creepy scene on top of the fact
that spiders already creeped me out
these big spiders are coming after him
he's landing in the spider webs and the
cool thing is he puts on the ring Bilbo
can hear the spiders talking to
themselves about them how they're gonna
eat him they're all speaking
Parseltongue and and it shows that
Bilbo is going down that dark rabbit
hole that Frodo is going down the little
crab spider things walking and it's
almost putting the ring on accidentally
Bobo stabs it in the head like 42 times
he holds the ring up he's like mine
you're like Oh Bilbo easy burglar they
crash at this shapeshifter dude's house
like a group of friends you don't want
to have really Ryan crashing my place
you don't see him a lot but it does show
you aspects of middle-earth that are out
there or at least one aspect cuz he's
the last one but it just shows you how
magical middle-earth can be I'm pretty
early on Gandalf splits off to go to his
own side quest with radagast the brown
there's a lot more normal in this movie
I'm just saying he did a lot less meth
crack or mushrooms or whatever it was
it's on his mind
cuz he's just a little more normal in
this movie a little more tame but they
need to go to dog all do er to find out
what the hell is happening there which
is a cool scene I like the scene it's
great in concept but it is one of the
scenes where I was like those effects
could have been cleaned up a little bit
Gandalf's in this magic fight his
bubbles compressing he's trying to hold
back evil and you see this necromancer
is really just these holding his own
against Gandalf the Grey like this
necromancer is business if you didn't
know who the necromancer was before you
know now this necromancer beats gandalf
pins them up against the wall and you
see the eye wreathed in flame you see
Sauron just walk out from it you're like
holy also voiced by Benedict
Cumberbatch which is funny comebacks
voices the two big
had ashes in this entire movie or entire
middle-earth trilogy Sauron and Smaug
the dragon because he just has the voice
how could you not put that voice in
everything
never that Gandalf gets put in a cage
somewhere they like yeah he just chill
out here for the rest of the movie wall
of the dwarves and the little Hobbit go
try to take on badassness zoo again any
goal saving one of the things I'm still
wondering about was the same thing I was
concerned about in the last Hobbit movie
which is in Fellowship of the Ring is
seemed Gandalf suspected Sauron was
coming back but he was like I don't
really know if he's actually coming
pinned up against a wall and seeing
Sauron emerge from a flaming I can't
also be like no I know I know what's
happening so I'm interested to see by
the end of this trilogy and then in the
Fellowship of the Ring how that actually
mixes in meshes I already talked about
the badass River action scene with the
barrels but I need to talk about it a
little more because it was such a cool
ceiling right about the time someone
took an axe and chucked it into an orc
and pinned him up against the log and
was just hanging there's dead bodies
just there I was like all right this is
cool lot of decapitations too if light a
loss came out of nowhere sliced off a
human's head and held it almost
tauntingly and then dropped it every
like is red it is a little rough it's
rated R but an organ I don't give a
about orcs they're not people they don't
vote and again the fact that Legolas is
in the movie could be seen as forced I
choose not to see it that way though
because Legolas his father is in the
movie and he said dick its own Thorin
he's like how about this I will help you
in thorns like yeah your word is
I've seen it I'd tell him the
same thing yeah I'd be rotting in the
Lothlorien jail cells too but I don't
care
anyhow Legolas his father is in the
movie so I would think it would be
logical that Legolas was also in the
movie you're like hey where's your kid
Legolas I don't know doing elf so
he should be here but he's not he wasn't
in the movie I would think that would be
more weird so the fact that he's in the
movie doesn't bother me bard was badass
too I like characters like him or he's
like hey there's a shitty town I'm a
really cool guy everyone likes me I'm a
people person he's the people's champion
of this town run by Sir Francis Drake
zombie that is what the dude who runs
that town looked like he looked like
loved him in V for Vendetta de
bards like I'm going to take out that
dragon with this
huge arrow harpoon thing and I can't
talk enough about Smaug that thing was
awesome everybody ranted about the damn
dragon in my last review there's no real
need to keep talking about it but I
think I might it really was enormous
just look at the scope of this thing
you're like good lord
not the Balrog of Morgoth boost huge
this thing is eed enormous claws are all
big and razor I love the fact that you
kept mockingly calling Bilbo barrel
right he's just so articulate you can
tell I wouldn't want to play chess
against the dude fire would be fine I
just don't want to feel like an idiot
get the dragon beat me at chess I'll
play Stratego I got buildup but that is
another part rob was like those effects
could have been cleaned up a bit not the
dragon not smiled or anything but it was
when they were all floating across the
goal the melted gold River I was like
that looks like PlayStation to their
credit I have never seen melted gold
maybe it looks exactly like that
probably not done and yeah I'm not gonna
lie when that gold came over smog I was
like alright I guess he's done for and
he busts out he shakes it I was like oh
you saw me wreck the town in the
prologue of The Hobbit there's you wait
you wait he flies towards the town
you're like you all are toes he's like I
am fire I am death oh right when it
happened where he really goes to show
you how much I was into this movie how
much I loved this movie because I never
checked my watch once I thought we still
had to see smiled wipe his ass with this
town right when he said I am deaf he
says the word death and the music shuts
off a split second before it went black
I was like oh you've got to be kidding
me
then it went black and I was like you
have got to be me
then the credits came on it was like
cliffhanger endings like that I love to
hate them I love them I really do they
may they give you that ah man kind of
feeling most movies that try to pull it
off I'm not interested enough to have
that on man kind of feeling but in this
movie I really had the ah man kind of
feeling and more than a few scenarios
the hobbit the desolation of smaug did
remind me of the Empire Strikes Back of
Hobbit movies right down to the scene
where Smaug is taunting Bilbo he's just
taunting the out of him he's
playing with him he can rock him at any
time he just gobble him up the whole
death he's really kind of taunting him
playing with everybody he's breathing
fire and people are taunting Hey
taunting back but at a point you seed it
reminded me of the scene in Empire
Strikes Back where Vader comes around
the corner and slashes up Luke he's
breathing hard he's it's whacking at
music alright playtime's over this is
business smile gets that same look he
just comes around the corner he's just
going out from his lair alright I was
messing with you now I want to murder
you all I was like I made it with wings
a girl I can't wait for the next movie
cannot wait for the next movie so yeah
spoiler free or spoiler however you want
to slice it I have a couple videos
telling you the hobbit the desolation of
smaug was completely awesome
unforgettable I want to see it again I
haven't seen it in 48 frames a second I
saw it in 24 so I am open to see it in
48 frames a second now that I have
already seen the movie in 24 you know
maybe next time so I'm not gonna ask you
if you liked the desolation of smaug I
already asked you that I will ask you
who do you think would win in a fight
Balrog of Morgoth or Smaug the dragon
seriously I want ScrewAttack to do a
death battle to really break it down as
to who would win because those are
entertaining and cool and I want to know
both are fire both use fire both are
impervious to fire who no no my friend
and I got into a debate on this we never
reached an answer so Balrog of Morgoth
or Smaug the dragon who do you think
would win in a fight whoever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more